postmanuel says NBC News defends we're
coming for your children chant at NYC
drag March arguing it's been used for
years at Pride events but it's it's it's
more than that they tweeted the coming
for your children chant has been used
for years at Pride events according to
long-time March attendees and gay rights
activists who said it's one of the many
provocative Expressions used to regain
control of slurs against lgbtq people
here's here's the funny thing
the new NBC news article says in the 21
second clip circulated by a right-wing
web streamer channel is that you that's
us by the way okay that's Tim guest news
former voice News Guard certified by the
way it says dozens of people in the
streets can be heard chanting we're here
we're queer we're not going shopping but
one voice that is louder than the crowd
it's not clear whose or whether the
speaker was a member of the lgbtq
community is heard saying at least twice
we're here we're coming for your
children
first of all in the video you can hear
they're all chanting people and you can
see their mouths yeah you can see
multiple people saying this thing no now
here's my point also notice they didn't
why add the clip they're linking it but
they didn't write that in this article
my point is this why are they
simultaneously arguing it's a totally
normal chance they always have done
and also nobody did it it's some it's
one weird person we don't know who that
person is which is it pick one now
here's where here's here's the good part
shoe on head tracked down one of the
sources
pointing out that NBC news said a
leaderless group of activists with the
radical fairies a loosen it lgbtq
Collective and the sisters of Perpetual
Indulgence a charity and protest group
have helped organize the march in more
recent years according to post there are
no sponsorships by companies at the drag
March do uh to just clarify NBC News is
reporting a leaderless group of
activists with the radical fairies
helped organize this March where they
chanted were coming for your children
okay thank you shun head for this one
Henry uh Harry hey uh hey Junior was an
American gay rights activist nambola
activist communist labor Advocate
co-founder of the medicine society as
well as the radical fairies
so it was an outright NAMBLA activist
what is that North American man boy love
Association the North American man boy
love Association so it was a communist
pedophile who founded this organization
that uh now goes on to help organize a
March in which they're chanting we're
coming for your children and NBC news
says nothing to see here folks shout out
by the way to elad eliyahu reporting for
timcast news on the ground who caught
this video and I want to stress this
when when elad tweeted this video out we
didn't think that much of it was like
here they go again people and then it
went crazy viral and it's gone this far
but uh shadowhead for pulling this
information up this is why you should
follow at timcast news on Twitter
because you would see a lot of stuff
first let's go which by the way the the
headline's so interesting uh it's not
that big of a deal because we've been
doing it for years
wait that doesn't make it better that
makes it worse that thing you're scared
about we've been doing it for longer
than you realize they've been writing
books about it since the I mean arrows
and Civilization by Herbert Hughes came
out in like the 60s or something like
that these are these Arguments for
intergenerational relationships have
been made by queer theorists for the
better part of 50 years this is a a this
is a normal leftist perspective if
you're a leftist like philosophers like
skull or whatever that is normal to hear
people will are going to feel more
comfortable as LGBT issues become more
topical people in Academia are going to
feel more comfortable making the
argument that there is nothing no such
thing as innocence that there is no
reason to prevent children from seeing
sexual activity being sexually active
themselves these are not arguments that
I'm making these are arguments that are
made by people like Michelle Foucault
Herbert Marcus and people that are
cutting edge
in the field of queer Theory and and
Communists yeah they're absolutely
they're all marxists they're all
leftists they're all they're you know
they're they're all Communists um but
when they organize an event we should
think nothing of it it's fine don't
question this I I I I think different
things than what you're saying so this
is like this article is so weird they're
they're Tim is totally right they're
they're saying we do this all the time
and also it's not a big deal there's
nothing and also that person's not a
part of our group and we don't even
believe it's real this is not a bad
thing this is right now this is a
resource if you look on Twitter the uh
actual tweet that NBC made had a has a
community notes thing on it and stuff so
that is a good thing and it should be
used by everybody that wants to fight
the left and the the literal attack on
children because what we're talking
about is their admission that they want
to Target children the specific reason
is because they want to interrupt the
way that adults raise their children
because grown-ups raise children that
are well adjusted and happy are not
revolutionary they don't end up in queer
Lifestyles generally they they just
don't end up in in you know doing a lot
of drugs and out on the street and the
left wants people in those conditions
because unhappy people are
revolutionaries happy satisfied people
are not revolutionaries and the left is
full of actual communist revolutionaries
so your kids are their target and that
is not an exaggeration they want to
raise your kids to be revolutionaries
they want to raise your kids to hate you
that is a true statement
sorry don't let your kids be on Tick
Tock no for real like the Vivek Rama
Swami right now saying kids under 16
should not be allowed on any of these
social apps like I think it's one of the
best political positions I've heard in a
long time because if you I'm fully
convinced if kids did not have Tick Tock
at 14 and did not I don't know what
you're allowed to say on YouTube but
corn they didn't have corn or they
didn't uh watch Tick Tock like I'm
convinced the trans thing wouldn't even
exist it's this weird fetish culture
paired with these Tick-Tock algorithms
that are just prolonging it and that is
why we have well you you have you have
children I I want people who have kids
to imagine this right I I just I mean I
shouldn't even say that anybody just
imagine this
you have a 12 year old
they go outside and they're walking
around by themselves and let's say
they're riding their bike they ride
their bike a few miles and they come
across an old Warehouse
to sex club they go inside by themselves
and there's a bunch of people engaged in
lewd and lascivious behaviors and they
all start talking to the kid and
inviting the kid over to partake that's
the internet the internet with your kids
on the Internet is you being like have
fun good luck and your kids could
stumble across
these sex clubs and they're going to see
these things and watch it and have
groomers groom them and we've heard this
for many uh individuals in fact what
you're referring to
we actually had a couple of d
transitioners
explain to us that they're going on in
places like Tumblr
and they'll get people saying like hey
why don't you try wearing some boys
clothes and see how you feel post some
pictures they do what happens next they
get bombarded by likes and comments
about how cool they are they feel good
then they say did you feel good when you
didn't like yeah it felt really good and
like do more
what actually feels good is the social
acceptance yeah belonging belonging yeah
and then they keep telling these kids to
do more and more and more and more and
that was the story we heard explicitly
from one detransitioned individual so
all that really matters
don't let your kids go to adult events
don't let your kids be exposed to us but
I agree with you vivek's position on
this stuff I we were talking about this
last night
if you go out in public and you hold up
a big sign a big picture of porn
you're gonna get arrested or at the very
least accounts are gonna take it from
you they're gonna cite you or arrest you
or it's like obscenity laws
if you speak your political mind you're
fine
if you go online and speak your
political mind you will be destroyed but
of course porn is everywhere and totally
acceptable on the internet so it's
backwards the internet is is is a is a
lawless Wild West place and a lot of
people are saying it's losing its Wild
West Edge and there were good things
about it when it was the Wild West in
fact in the in that you could have a
decentralized network of your friends
actually doing productive things but
what happened was the internet started
with a bunch of tech nerds
and that's why you end up with in the
early days cool things happening online
cool stories then people who want to
hide from the mainstream start using it
and you get weirdos using the internet
and weird things on the internet
now you have the mainstreaming and the
centralization of the internet where
everything's becoming more like apps
it's it's less free less free-flowing
less less about the domain and more
about the app you're using
but still we've not codified anything to
say keep kids out of these adult
facilities these on the internet that
needs to happen yep yeah I don't think
think there's a benefit to it I was
thinking about recently
um I wrote this story about how Middle
School test scores are sort of tanking
and this we saw a huge drop in the
National report card in 2012. and for me
it's impossible I know I can't prove
correlation or causation but uh Snapchat
got released in July of 2011 and uh
Instagram got released in October of
2010 and I think
it's interesting because a specific
study talked about how fewer kids choose
to read for fun uh on their own and
that's true of all performance levels
and now you wonder what are they doing
are they outside running around more are
they what no they're all on Tick Tock
they're on Instagram they're on Snapchat
they're completely devoted to the screen
and it's they're suffering because of it
again there are probably lots of things
that factor into this but I don't think
we can deny that social media has
changed childhood or at least
preteenthood forever and I don't know
that it's beneficial people who say oh
you have to connect with people and find
your community like shouldn't we be
encouraging kids to do this in person to
have in-person conversations and to find
communities that they see face to face
that we know are not someone else there
was a reason that show Catfish got so
popular right because it reminds you
constantly that you don't know exactly
who you're talking to on the internet
unless you have actually met them and if
it can happen to you when you're you
know 21 and talking to someone online
think of what can happen to basically an
even more gullible child who gets online
at 12. yeah well and it's so widespread
and sadly like
most of society does not live on Twitter
and see these videos go viral we have
340 million people in our country the
vast majority of them will never see
that video of that chant so what's
concerning is you'll tell them they're
trying to groom your kids look they're
admitting it but they don't see that
like most average moms and dads still
believe that the public schools are
wonderful our teachers would never groom
the kids they're not actually they just
want a quality like they're again a lot
of people stuck in this they don't
realize it's changing I hope so but but
Bud Light proves it that's that's prove
it that's true once it becomes that
mainstream my problem is is that there's
still too much of a denial that our
country has related to things like this
do you remember two years ago when the
San Francisco gay choir during Zoom came
out and literally sang we're coming for
your children it's like they've been
telling us for years what they're trying
to do why are we just now waking up to
it I think part of the reason why why
we're just now waking up to it is is
because people have not had a lot
there's not been a lot of voices
articulating
what the actual intent is like the fact
that the that there is a a an effort
made by people on the left to interrupt
the raising of children so that way they
can change their opinions to be a
socialist opinion that's looked at as a
conspiracy theory right
I I think that's only one small element
of it I I think the bigger picture is
just that
the Occam's razor suggest they're people
who are want to abuse kids thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time